je suis né du mauvais côté Benoît
magimis et mécanaissable et formidable
dans Edwig et le pot s'en Fury il y
interprète une chanteuse est allemande
établie aux États-Unis qui raconte sa
vie et son parcours en musique c'est un
personnage qui peut faire peur dans blé
en disant qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
là mais on s'en approche on voit
l'humanité derrière tout ça on voit si
on pourrait avoir des préconçues par
rapport à c'est pas une drag queen parce
que c'est un jeune homosexuel à
Berlin-Est qui pour traverser de l'autre
barre subit subit et le mot est juste à
dire un subit un changement de sexe qui
lui-même dit un peu botcher donc tous
parce que ce pouce en furie c'est le
pouce qui lui reste comme organe génital
alors donc il est devenu une chanteuse
qui se promène à travers le monde c'est
très déstabilisant comme spectacle
ça parle aussi principalement c'est la
recherche de son autre moitié de la
quête de l'amour puis qui va pouvoir
nous accompagner dans notre vie quand on
est différent ou quand on est qui on est
[Musique]
frontières entre les genres à tous les
égards ce théâtre musical qui ne
ressemble à rien d'autre il est question
d'amour de séparation et d'identité
c'est très particulier mais comme en
même temps c'est un show punk
avec des balades super touchantes
parfois un personnage exubérant mais en
même temps hyper sensible
présenté pour la première fois offre
Broadway 25 ans le spectacle écrit par
John Cameron Mitchell a aussi fait
l'objet d'une adaptation
cinématographique devenue culte
cette histoire hors du temps continue de
réjouir et détenir je trouve que ça peut
rejoindre tout le monde c'est chaud là
quand on prend la l'ouverture puis de
faire j'ai envie que quelqu'un vienne à
moi puis je suis prêt mais ça marche pas
tout le temps c'est ce qui est dégrade
après le studio TD à Montréal éveillez
le poisson furie partiront tourné
partout au Québec ici Nabil Alexandre
Chartier Radio-Canada